im oberpfälzischen landkreis cham sollen
brandneue glasfaserleitungen verlegt
werden endlich soll schnelles internet
her
in ober trauben bach reißen bautrupps
des münchner
telekommunikationsunternehmens m-net
alle straßen auf aber glasfaser wird
nicht verlegt überall gucken nur leere
plastikrohre aus dem boden eine
chaotische aktion ohne sinn und verstand
es hat plötzlich über nacht hier im dorf
20 arbeiter aus allen ecken und enden
gesprungen und haben dort wirkte
schütteln umfang das ist
geldverschwendung ist es planlos ist es
hirnlos ohne nachzudenken irgendwas zu
machen das geht halt einfach es ist ein
schild bericht ist es den auftrag den
landkreis cham mit hochgeschwindigkeits
internet auszustatten ergattert die
firma endet das münchner unternehmen
gehört diversen bayerischen städten und
kommunen die bauarbeiten den kamen
verlaufen chaotisch es wird kreuz und
quer gebuddelt
aber dann werden die arbeiten plötzlich
gestoppt ohne dass die firma einen meter
glasfaser verlegt hat die erklärung
dafür ist kurios beim ausbau projekt in
cham wurde im projektverlauf deutlich
dass das ausbauvorhaben für endet
wirtschaftlich nicht realisierbar ist
abenteuerlich nach ein paar
spatenstichen merken sie im fernen
münchen dass es sich hier in cham nicht
lohnt wie viel geld sie in der oberpfalz
in den sand gesetzt haben will uns die
m-net nicht sagen damit sie aus dem
vertrag mit dem landkreis wieder
rauskommt wird jetzt eine
millionenschwere abstandszahlung fällig
also über die höhe der abstandszahlung
wurde zwischen beiden partnern
einvernehmlich stillschweigen vereinbart
unglaublich die summe wird einfach
totgeschwiegen in münchen rechnet man
mit einem zweistelligen millionenbetrag
für den steuerzahler
denn die stadtwerke der bayerischen
landeshauptstadt sind der größte
anteilseigner an der m net im stadtrat
ist man stinksauer
es sind millionenverluste entstanden
außerhalb von münchen nämlich in cham
und jetzt muss der münchner steuerzahler
diese kosten übernehmen und diese
verluste tragen das ist ein
unglaublicher vorgang in cham sind die
menschen auch bedient ihm wurde
schnelles internet versprochen bekommen
haben sie ruinierte straßen
jeder private unternehmer wäre schon
bleibt immer wenn er so wirtschaft
finanzen aber auch zu spesen nichts
gewesen
das ist wahrscheinlich mein geld koste
das wird auch wieder mehr geld kosten
aber gebraucht hat eigentlich ein dorf
oder landkreis der kammer landkreis hat
aus dem glasfaser reinfall die
konsequenzen gezogen und wird jetzt in
eigenregie bauen ohne hilfe aus der
landeshauptstadt